hey how are you doing i am doing great
how about yourself i'm good okay before
we get into candyman and it scared the
crap out of me on a sunday morning at 10
a.m that's a good sign of a good movie
um you have so many amazing projects on
the go candyman the new matrix aquaman
two you got an emmy for watchmen
how does it feel being the ick guy in
hollywood right now
um
i i won't go so far as to say about
being a guy that's that is that's that's
none of my business uh but i'm blessed
uh you know i i've worked very hard you
know for the position that i'm that i
find myself in and i'm and i'm so
ambitious to do a whole lot more i think
uh i'm i'm
i'm i'm still you know still climbing
and still looking to find you know the
best stories out there for me to tell so
so i'm i'm not resting that's for sure
i love that well you're just so engaging
on camera i'm not surprised by all of
your success so let's talk about
candyman i think what i love so much
about this one uh compared to the
original because i'm a huge fan of
horror films that we really get to see
the backstory of candyman was that
something that
interested you
yeah for sure you know uh i think
telling telling a little bit more about
the candy man's backstory about this
figures backstory allows us to uh as an
audience be a bit more empathetic you
know to his story to his own experience
you know i think previously we have
candyman as a villain in our in our
minds this one gives us the opportunity
to imagine him and to understand him as
a more complex character uh and you know
he still
is not to be crossed you know and he
still has you know he still is out you
know he he still is as dangerous as he
was in the first one um so so even
though he's an opposing figure
i think our story gives us a chance to
you know to give a little bit more heart
to the candy man experience yeah
absolutely and you transforming into
candyman oh my god every time the hand
oh i could handle it
was that fun
yeah you know it's it's fun making
movies like that uh it is
it's fun you know seeing how far you
know how deep into the character you
know i can get it
uh and having you know having fun with
that on set and things like that that
makes for some pretty cool uh moments in
between the in between the tapes also
i love that okay so have you had enough
courage you know outside of this film to
say can demand five times in front of a
mirror
uh absolutely not i'm not
i'm not about that life as they say i'm
not about that life at all i want no
parts because the thing look here's the
thing you never know when candy man is
going to come sometimes he'll show up
immediately and then he may not show up
for another two weeks or two months so
i want i like my life like we said you
know just a couple minutes ago i got a
good little streak going i want to keep
it that way as long as possible
you don't want to mess up the it guys
status in hollywood i don't want it i
don't want to mess up nothing i don't
want to mess up nothing everything is
great
he can stay where he had in the movie
who in your family is excited to see you
as candy man and who do you know would
just can't watch this because they're
going to be too scared
uh
my
my nephews and my sisters are very very
excited to watch it
um
and my mama is probably the one in my
family who's a little bit like
she's gonna see it you know she gonna
see it but she's gonna see it with with
her fists up like this you know
maybe i love that
yeah i love that so much now you've
already said just as i'm wrapping up
that you know you were so star struck by
ken reeves on the new matrix film but
fans have been wanting this film for so
long what are you excited for like the
die hard fans to see
um
i'm excited to see how how we can you
know bring some of those characters back
and bring that story back 20 years later
you know uh the technology that that
matrix introduced back in what 1999
at the you know turn of you know into
into the new millennium you know uh it
was
really uh stunning and you know it held
up and i'm uh you know hopefully we can
introduce some really cool new things
you know on this one as well so uh
there's a lot there's a lot for those
fans and a lot for new fans also
and carries is still a badass
oh every day every day of the week every
day of the week
that's awesome hey congratulations on
this film it's so good especially i'm
such a huge fan of horror films so yeah
this is a good one
thank you very much i appreciate it yeah
nice meeting you all right peace
you